en este vídeo me gustaría hacer algunos
ejemplos para practicar la derivada como
una tasa de cambio de una curva o como
la pendiente de una curva o mejor dicho
como la pendiente de una recta que pasa
tangente por la curva dependiendo de
como quieran verlo entonces aquí tenemos
f prima de 5 y esta anotación
es decir escribir esta prima es otra
forma de decir cuál es la derivada
entonces nos dicen estima la derivada de
la función en 5 y en este caso cuando
decimos f prima de 5 está es la
pendiente
pendiente de la recta tangente
la recta tangente
5 o también lo podemos ver como la tasa
de cambio tasa de cambio
de que
con respecto a x
así es como se define la pendiente de
nuestra función f ahora pensemos en esto
un poco como podemos ver aquí tenemos el
punto 55 entonces si queremos estimar la
pendiente de la recta tangente
es decir si queremos saber qué tan
empinada se encuentra esta curva podemos
dibujar una recta que pase tangente por
ese punto entonces hagamos eso vamos a
dibujar una recta tangente más o menos
así y justo en ese punto podremos saber
qué tan empinada está la curva ahora lo
que lo hace interesante es que esto no
es lineal cambia constantemente miren
aquí la pendiente de la curva es muy
pequeña pero después va aumentando
conforme nos movemos hacia la derecha es
decir entre más grandes sean los valores
de x pero si analizamos el punto en
cuestión cuando x es igual a 5 recuerde
nos piden f prima de 5
a la pendiente de esta recta cada vez
que nos movemos una posición en la
dirección x nos movemos dos posiciones
en el eje de delta que es igual a 2
cuando delta x es igual a 1 entonces el
cambio en jake con respecto a x al menos
para esta recta tangente que representa
nuestro cambio en jake con respecto a x
justo en este punto es igual a 2 entre 1
y eso es igual a 2 ok y todas estas
opciones están fuera porque miren una
derivada negativa significa que conforme
incrementamos x se disminuye y en este
caso en realidad tendríamos una
pendiente de menos 2 ahora si tuviéramos
una pendiente igual a 0.1 esa sería una
pendiente muy pequeña y la tenemos por
aquí y una pendiente de menos 1 se
encuentra por este lado es una pendiente
muy pequeña mientras que una pendiente
igual a cero
significaría que nos encontramos en este
punto en el que al cambiar x ya no
aumenta ni disminuye la pendiente de una
recta tangente que pasa por este punto
es igual a cero así que nuestra
respuesta es correcta hagamos otro
aquí nos piden que comparemos la
derivada de g en 4 y la derivada de g en
6 cuál será mayor
bueno como siempre los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y lo intenten ustedes
primero ok vamos a ver si trazamos una
línea para indicar la pendiente vamos a
dibujar una recta tangente que pase por
este punto
ahí está bueno esta línea que acabo de
dibujar nos indica la tasa de cambio de
y con respecto a equis o mejor dicho la
pendiente de la curva pues ésta es una
recta tangente y podemos pensar en la
pendiente ahora si analizamos este punto
al parecer aquí la pendiente es más
empinada pero en dirección negativa
entonces mire si por ejemplo
incrementamos uno de x
podemos ver que disminuye uno de iu
entonces al parecer que prima de 4 es
decir la derivada cuando x es igual a 4
es aproximadamente
- 1 mientras que en este punto cuando
incrementamos uno de equis parece que
disminuye aproximadamente 3
entonces g prima de 6 es aproximadamente
igual a menos 3 así que cuál es más
grande bueno este es menos negativo por
lo tanto este es mayor y bueno también
podemos hacer esto intuitivamente si
observamos la curva aquí tenemos una
especie de si no soy de observen que en
este punto la función es plana no hay
cambio en jake con respecto a x pero
después empieza a bajar y después sigue
bajando pero la tasa de cambio disminuye
hasta que en este momento la pendiente
de la recta tangente es igual a 0 y
después la pendiente vuelve a
incrementar y eso sucede una y otra vez
así que también podemos verlo desde un
punto de vista más intuitivo